greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Squarespace listen to me easily
create a website by yourself
make it yourself make it stand out stand
out with a beautiful website ready to
start your new business get started with
Squarespace you think it you dream it
and you make it which quest based
destiny is calling it says you need a
new website make it with Squarespace the
future is coming make it brighter with
Squarespace what I'm gonna do is I want
you to head over to Squarespace calm
right now again go over that Squarespace
calm right now for a free trial when
you're ready to launch when you ready to
make your dream a reality
use the offer code Church and save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain did you hear what I just said
when you're ready to go when you're
ready to make that dream a reality
go to squarespace.com and use offer code
Church to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain alright
number two this podcast is brought to
you by on it listen it's february 126
and you're still digging around it's
time for you to go to on it dot-com
right now and get some offer brain a
little shrimp tonight full season is
always upon you know these creepy
[ __ ] they're always building
their breathing on you
you need some shooting tech immune from
shrimp export they got the best protein
to business to listen who the [ __ ]
mind go to Anna calm right now you see
something you're like on the way out go
to the box and press in search BAM and
get 10% off delivered right to the
[ __ ] cars okay take this [ __ ] muley
pick up the pieces and go home that's
shock huh what's up Jess maybe was doing
you know man
the pilots and pirates yeah it's good
weed all the time you look like the
personification of being high like your
whole face looks like my nightmare
your face is people with roofie pills
and limite sir
I've seen women pass out after Barnet's
you give them two jobs let the alcohol
in them you let a girl get high first
then you hit her with the bong is that
with 28% it's over I feel nothing you
got about 40 women and they start
you got two minutes put him in the head
with a bucket because there was it shake
them and how I know this like people
think she's I'm a [ __ ] animal here but
that you are an invalid on guard guard
why mistreated gas Ralphy man and all
the people in that building there was a
girl that did eyebrows and all that [ __ ]
yeah not the best looking girl in the
world was very sweet and she would come
over to our friends house and we would
like do it every Friday and sad
he would do it it was like a group thing
like if you were you in Ralphy man a
train we want me Ralphie's Gavin all of
us would sit around on Fridays and watch
a movie before we go out to the candy
store whatever yeah and this girl would
always come downstairs and say can I get
high with you guys and it was like the
same thing every [ __ ] week for six
weeks until somebody said no no more she
would have wine red wine and we had
glasses of red wine and catatonic she
was a type of broad that if she was a
mine somebody would probably give me a
stabbing yeah like people like what we
do well she was a little chunky and they
just pick her up but always crazy girl
this poor girl and every Friday she was
very sweet she'd do your eyebrows for
free and [ __ ] did you get your eyebrows
even tremble oh that's nice yeah yeah
those things are intense is a [ __ ]
yeah I've been [ __ ] 50 like they grow
out losing their hair over here so what
I'm gonna do is the brow back it'll be
quite like the brow back they call the
other yeah this times I have my wife
cuts it before I leave yeah I'll sit in
the toilet with lights cameras and
[ __ ] flashlights
she'll trim them and then you go to a
hotel you check-in you go to the
bathroom to pee and what do you see when
you wash your face that one one brown
and it's [ __ ] an inch long and now I
gotta get a scissor in college I called
my wife I'd call her
you missed you missed you missed one oh
yeah I got hand those shoes shoe [ __ ]
shaved my nose and two days later
there's another half row by those older
like you just watch and when I was doing
coke I had no hair my nose is I had like
a Brazilian wax of my nose two three
years I can feel the hairs like growing
it's a [ __ ] night it's like you turn
into a creature
you guys aren't Jewish what do you ty
I'm the one who has to shave my back my
ears - why do you have to shave your
back
how bad is it it's a sweater is it oh
yeah well maybe she moved to a colder
climate and make it be useful it is
useful for what she cleaning off the
dirt off the bottom of shoes just
recently shaving oh I have to man
groomers you have to man its capers in
case one of them writes ya oh I'm
picturing people you mean a device yeah
it's a device like go back it's like a
back scratcher but it you do it by
yourself that's a saddest thing I've
ever heard of Lee you need to go have a
lady do that for you when I had a
girlfriend she didn't like me to shave
it cuz she said it would get pregnant
when I came back yeah it comes back
prickly and it feels offensive but you
need to have like a lady take care I
don't mean like a girlfriend I mean go
to like a lady and have it like wax I
just can't picture you wax like you're
shaving your back yourself what are you
doing oh yeah what about how my he's
gonna be the Wolfman and [ __ ] he's
gonna have me what I mean 10 years
already
he's got the hummus neck already you
missed me mix the hummus neck with that
head I mean Lee oh he gets you all that
hair it's in between the back with the
cortisol that gets released from his
neck it it smells like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right in between his neck there I want a
[ __ ] get sweaty has an onion little
miss to it an onion miss my next smells
great my next like document that I'm
podcasting podcast we talk about a
[ __ ] fly off I remember a fly being
you always be in that corner by him
because it was warm and I had to talk to
Mantha man you gotta stop watching in
there no and so this is my washer that
I'm I have a loofah mind you okay and
it's the red one and what's the old
spice or somebody yeah that's what I use
because that's good because I'm just
sure I want to be sure takes off that
hummus next smell I know I don't have a
thumbs out of your neck listen that's
what the very good at science i went to
vegas and i what the uh i want to thank
the people came out to the Vegas show
and also the people who came out to the
tucson short the fox neither you guys
were [ __ ] phenomenal audiences i went
to those places and then sunday I was
too tired to work out cuz it was three
planes on one day you're looking
fabulous by the way they said it took
three days off so today I went to
kickboxing this morning I smell that
shirt it's not like Turkey did you have
all these shirt yeah yeah you know how
you smell when I took the shirt off yeah
back on the put the other shirt before I
left the gym because you don't want to
keep put that you know you can't I like
I like your style
you smell yep I [ __ ] smelt that shirt
later on I'm smelling around me tonight
like Turkey and [ __ ] salt yeah and
pills and nothing I said you got anxiety
pills Saturday night dessert and with
some coffee but just those two three
days without sweat yeah you could smell
what comes out yeah those weeks without
sweat sweat podcast ago that I've been
going on that working on things so ya
know he the last three months but before
that he would sweat and he would come in
here and it would be hot in the summer
and a dog and then you sweat and heat
sweat a little bit
wedding amount he found like a scorpion
in the corner if I found a score it was
a became it was something yeah I never
come here again
and to be what this dingleman left how
much is a natural be deterrent I wish
that was true outside of myself going on
your world how is that for people don't
know God knock is where you go to
showcase so College
just we'll hire you for big money they
give used to give your rental car yeah I
first moved in 97 if you were doing
colleges it was like you were making
thirty five hundred a night a [ __ ]
car a rental car cause you got to drive
an hour they gave you a money for a
rental car now you got to get your own
cars okay yeah but old days you got a
car jack yeah now they don't do that now
now you're gonna do it yourself but you
know I went a day early just to kind of
check it out you know just to see what
the process was cuz it is it's a bunch
of college students and everyone's got
the right to be offended now and I was
like I'm just gonna go do my thing you
know I don't know what how else to do it
I'm just gonna do what I do instead of
trying to like manipulate my set to fit
some mold that I'm not even sure if it
would work in the first place and I had
a host the night Joe I had a host it
I'd host the whole thing I had to bring
up magicians and to bring up a [ __ ]
medium lady out there like a tea a B a J
I can't how to bring how does that work
how does that go over with little bit
crazy
guest a lot of stuff her and her husband
they were guessing stuff that was right
they were guessing names in all sorts of
information from people I don't know how
the hell they were doing it but I had to
bring up a magician I had to bring up a
medium I had to bring up a musician like
two comics and so honestly am I set like
just I felt like I ate a bag of dicks
I feel like everyone I know it's done
neck I feels like they've eaten a bag of
dicks you know what I mean like the
college shows it's just but afterwards
so I'm performing I'm like all right
this is not going the way I want it to
go I'm just gonna get through it have as
much fun as I can
I ended on a [ __ ] torte contest
between a a like college administrator
and a couple other students I had him up
on stage I was like I'm just gonna have
some fun and go crazy with these kids
they went nuts because of that because
there was like an administrator up on
stage Dennis doing work and it's like
middle-aged dude working and then I go
to the booth and I'm walking over with
Christian from CAA I'm like I don't know
how that went he's like that was great
and like I don't know bro like I
appreciate it but as a comedian on the
inside
I'm dying a slow death still and I'm off
stage now is it still you go there's
boots yeah you so we go to the booth and
we couldn't keep up with the people who
came to the booth we we were so packed
with people coming to meet me and talk
to me and I thought I ate such a large
day you know you got a couple colleges
yeah like a whole bunch god bless you
that's what I was saying I like but I
thought well that's I'll tell you if I I
still remember doing this [ __ ] room I
used to do for money and I've told Lee
about it in the audience in the podcast
and those are the worst nights of my
life as a comedian like I was going
through something really bad at that
dialogue through the ugly divorce and I
would do comedy to take my mind off the
divorce I focused on calmly to take my
mind off the anger and the frustration
and have some place to put it but there
was one night a week where I would have
to go do comedy in a place that at the
beginning was fun but then towards the
middle it paid my rent yeah contributed
to my cocaine to have it they put gas in
my car the guy took care of me and he
fed me well every time I'd sit there I'd
be Britton my heart would be breaking
inside and when I moved from Denver one
of the happiest day one of the happiest
things I had was that I knew I never had
to go back there again
and it was the Elvis impersonator from
Vegas no that was just fat and old and
ugly and he would make great pasta but
then he would be an Elvis impersonator
in his own restaurant but he liked me
and he would give me another guy work
every Wednesday I never would have to do
sets in between the Elvis impersonator
and from time to time one of his friends
from Vegas would drop it and you know
what a bunch of fake credits and the guy
was power born he would sing like a song
like Frankie Valli do it yeah yeah my
heart would break guys I got nothing
against Frankie Valli
I got nothing gets Elvis but Elvis
impersonators like clowns for some
people they just don't like them every
synthetic because I couldn't believe
that at that age like it's like me right
now at 56 if I said [ __ ] calmly and with
[ __ ] disgusting body I'm gonna go be
a Elvis impersonator real pop chops and
then open up my own restaurant and sing
during the show oh man they sounded
nothing like I was I'm sure I'm sure he
sounded like I imagined a goat in pain
and when he would try to do Elvis it was
even worse ahh Oh guys it was painful
painful inside and it was like a small
75 maybe a small 50 I don't remember
what it was maybe the small hundred I
don't and sometimes you got tips in the
people ah you know it was just
heartbreaking to do but I had to do it
because it was part of my number yep for
the week it was part of that goal and
Denver had slim pickins yep you know but
there's been situations where you go oh
what about penguins penguins in Iowa
they booked me for a week and then they
call me thinking we've got a special
night on Wednesdays we do pays like a
GNote LaRue is something I'm like a
GNote let's talk about this yeah
especially midweek so I thought it was
at the club it was like you had to land
at the airport and then take a puddle
jump up
Oh Dan I have mr. love thank God picked
my ride there was a bowling alley
that's like that's like a Bill Hicks
style it was a bowl it was a [ __ ]
Paula
and would you perform on the lanes know
back in the bowling alley while people
were bowing whoa
could you hear like them hitting balls
and strike the owner like guitar acts so
the head of MC in the feature of guitar
axe and the headliner was music should
always end all that you want to talk
about slowed that bowl and I'm gonna go
I Love You Man when can you come back
and looking at straining you're like bad
luck you have to resurrect me from the
dead come on man bring Joe Rogan with
you listen if I brought Joe Rogan with
me he would shoot this boat how long ago
was it this had to be 94 mm Wow 2005
that's not that that's not that long ago
that was 13 years ago I came like 2005
was 13 years ago what the [ __ ]
14 years ago let's be honest no this had
to be June of 2005 The Longest Yard came
out in May of 2005
that's whole summer I did a tour like a
deep deep I got an agent in fact it was
Mike Berkowitz who's that
Wow yeah they had an agency in Burbank
and Bill burr got me with it because I
said Bill got this movie coming up maybe
have an opportunity to get me into a
couple clubs so bill called him they
called me and they booked me straight
awesome did they and it was just a
confessor oh just be going out there
would you just wake up and do blow no I
would wait till nighttime like a normal
really wicked normal I was that regular
life in the daytime yeah
towards the end yeah I was but would you
sleep if you're doing coke at night it
doesn't mess up with did you ever sleep
I'll go home and you have to take a
little nap why the people Tommy I go
home to write I would step to about four
or five Spartans I'd sleep from five to
why they dirty cannot be breakfast go do
my errands we were saying this before ha
like you and you were saying you were
happy like you're still alive how are
you still alive after you've lived such
a hard life it wasn't a hard life though
yeah but I mean not sleeping and doing
blow you'd sleep 3-4 hours
not enough Joe we've briefed or did you
catch too windy afternoon you're 30
years old
you're built like a iron when you tell
you iron I just I started napping in
1995 that's when I was introduced to the
nap
I was already 32 [ __ ] years old I
dated a stripper that worked till 5:00
in the morning so what she wanted a
stabbing in the afternoon how to take a
nap my mom didn't let me that we came
from Cuba my dad died so she was on the
run oh my god it's your neck that he
takes his face out and pops his breath
right into it I can't smell this so that
was you had a good experience then yes
before the show you like I don't know
how many cars you think you got I don't
know I mean we got like five Oh 45 a
male's thank God
god bless you I mean who knows how
that's gonna turn out cuz still another
process but it was a learning it was
definitely a learning process
and I'd message one of my comedian
friends Jamie Lee who was in the neck
episode of the of crashing you know Pete
Holmes shows and I watched that the
night before just to see what their take
of it was and it was I texted Jamie I'm
like yep I'm at NACA and I'm going
through the episode right now she yells
oh yeah you wanted to do what she wanted
yeah and she does like you know she does
rape jokes and told not to do rape jokes
and she she really accomplished yeah
Jamie Lee yeah she her character name in
the episode is Allie but yet I mean her
character in that show is really good
she's so natural yeah she's so I just
saw her the other day I'm like your
acting is so it's so hard to give
[ __ ] compliment like I don't
know about you but like I went to give
her I was like your acting is so good
and she's like you know typical comedian
just doesn't want to like accept that no
we don't want it it's like yeah just
yeah yeah you don't you don't want to
accept that you're actually what you're
doing is good happy that you get when
you see one of your friends on to you
I'm it's the great thing about Larkin
you like God saying it's the greatest
thing in the world to see that it really
is just to see people you've grown up in
the industry with doing stuff and not
you know being stuck working at some
nine-to-five with a boss you know
yelling into their hummus neck it's so
weird to make the jump once you get the
smell of blood yeah to get the taste of
blood you like a shark okay yep you know
no this is what I have to do cuz
everybody thinks oh oh I have an agent
that's great that's great yeah you gotta
go get breakdown you still gotta go
weepy you do everything go do it you
have to do in just yeah it's that thing
where there's so many other comics that
are like oh I just need an agent I just
need a manager and then what you think
anything changes when you know nothing
changes nothing changes you even get an
agent or manager you have to be the one
you have to be the one that's hungry and
hustling and emailing and delegating and
saying I want to do this make this
happen this is my next thing put me in
the room with this person like you
that's why I you know so many of us go
nuts because it's like that's so much to
consider but you have to be the hutt you
have to be the core of the hustle mm
maybe 99 to 2003 Jimmy Schubert would
get breakdown yeah email him to me and
then I would email him to Josh wolf
breakdowns every day yeah okay so that
was the first thing I did in the morning
I would wake up from one of those coke
Hayes's I drink some more issues to be
coffee No
did you yeah that's right I get the
breakdowns at 6:00
that's early for can I had to have to
break down some my manager by the time
you got in the office Wow whatever I
thought I was good for I had to happen
to my agent on my own yeah so I would
sit there with glasses isn't like a
breakdown through a hundred and forty
page when you sit down for [ __ ] an
hour and just what I'm looking at
everything piece of paper and a pen
casting director the name of the project
the project you want to go in for and
then after you write all that down you
got a [ __ ] email you manage it that's
good man for this submit me for that
I'm gonna call this [ __ ] jewel Larry
Johnson booked me if I might be blue
I'll call our office I don't you know
and now you set the strategy in the
office that was the first day never mind
stand up yeah like never mind stay no
that's aside from it was two hours a day
just focusing on acting yeah and then
[ __ ] I would see submissions like in
from around the corner from me forgiving
who's summer paramount when I lived in
Hollywood I'd do it before 9/11 you just
want a lot yeah I would just go and drop
it personally at the [ __ ] office hi
how you doing today I want to drop this
off for the show with uh that's how I
got the show what's her name
what's the [ __ ] dude Ben step Ben
Affleck what's his wife's name Jennifer
Lawrence Jennifer garden had a show
before a TV show we know the tough chick
oh yeah alias yeah yeah yeah I walked on
the lot and brought a headshot
and the assistant saw me and said you'll
be great for about a while and she
called the casting director the casting
director call me direct from the
headshot that was part of the hustling
that was your morning hustle that was
your hustle that's wrong then you want
to met the boys and ate lunch and you
picked up some [ __ ] and you'd have an
audition and you bump into somebody and
they go do they call you into this you
call them for that they looking for
girls just like you saw you at the
[ __ ] audition on your manager yo I
just bumped into a girl that's it
they're looking for a blonde
yeah Chino movie oh that's that movie
silence yeah I already picture ready all
right yeah you get the ball rolling
they're on top of things you know it
just doesn't come to your [ __ ] door
it doesn't you go home you sit for a
half hour right so calmly
then the store calls you says you got
two spots and Felipe Esparza April what
are you doing tonight bro ten o'clock it
pays 40 dollars in a burrito
you know yep
you got 11:15 at the store you know the
store is gonna be running late so you
had to make it all the way down to
Orange County all the way back to the
store by 11:15 same amount of traffic
even more sometimes it's like that's
when they're moving that's what their
move yeah they're going from their
second you know it was like you would
get home at 1:00 in the morning and
guess what at 7 o'clock your phone would
start yeah Joey grab a pen tomorrow
11:15 Sunshine Studios you're
auditioning for the part of Luke the
sides are on top that that that yeah so
you had to go on a website pay for a
[ __ ] the three pages a dollar each a
dollar is she that's wild and then 10
cents to print email at oh no no no it
never ended it never and I still never
getting sighs sent to the store I just
sent them to the store does that pick
them up yeah it's my easiest it's about
that I'm already out yep stop not in
this town
yeah you cannot add an extra stop that's
four hours round trip anywhere in this
town especially midday but I had a lot
of friends who work backup and they were
making money but the thing with knack is
what happens that eventually you lose
your mind yeah it's two years of doing
material or Peas done right and you're
in dumbing dumbing down what you want to
do yeah but you have a wife and a kid so
now you blowing up inside now you going
on those NACA trips and you snort Nadeem
pills and doing everything you [ __ ]
can because you can't say [ __ ] that
[ __ ] lizard on stage yeah can't say
that from your joke I I still am edgy
but I
definitely I mean what happened to
nimesh he was there nimesh told the
story about what happened when he got
pulled off the collar at the stage when
he was performing at college remember
that What did he say he the joke was
somewhere along the lines of he would
pass by this black gay guy where he
lived I'm probably butchering like the
setup but basically there was this black
gay guy whose path he would cross
regularly they got him thinking about
you know the origins of being gay and
like how nobody would choose that you
know especially if you're black you
wouldn't also want to be gay the joke
was how like you know being black is
enough why would you also want to be a
homosexual it's basically the the brunt
of the joke and that's what got him
pulled off stage just bowled Jada no you
got I think someone came up and actually
cut off they cut off his microphone and
he told that story at NACA I thought
that was kind of interesting that he you
know had so much press about that and
had the balls at the neck a conference
to talk about it and to tell the joke
again in like there was a couple of
comedians on the side and this was a
date you know before my conference I
just like that's that's pretty baller
that's pretty badass
- he's like I'm gonna tell the joke
again and he got the same reaction that
he said he got before complete silence
but we were laughing cuz the way he told
it and how he said it I thought it was a
very intelligent look at what's going on
in society but if you can't see beyond
your own offense in front of your eyes
to what the end goal of that joke is and
you're of course you're gonna be [ __ ]
offended you don't get it you don't get
what the [ __ ] he's trying to say Oh 36
do you when we get an offender than 18
no I wasn't you know the things I got
humbled early in life not a lot of stuff
did a lot of [ __ ] rolls off my back my
mom always called me her California baby
I'm very like laid back and then you
know things happen to me my life where I
just I don't get offended offended
offensive of
fence is in action it doesn't take
anything to be offended you know it's
not it's not a effective and change you
know what I mean it's just it's just a
stagnant thing or you're offended now
what because if you're just gonna be
offended shut the [ __ ] up but if you're
gonna be offended and then maybe have
that drive you to do something okay we
can have a conversation then but if
you're just gonna sit on your computer
and troll [ __ ] on the on the
Internet
I got a I got something to tell you
there's nothing going on for you I don't
remember being y'all thing that's always
still stuck with me because I'm such a
prude deep deep deep down inside are you
yeah very much so
wow I think so your religious background
yeah yeah and I died I had a challenge
yeah like if I was supposed to be raised
too high I I would listen to them I'm
not supposed to like gay people because
of my religious right we've seen and my
Cuban beliefs right I didn't believe
like that right that wasn't mine that's
that's stupid cuz you were taught back
my mother's side was like no damn that
meant day human beings the other side of
the Cuban men machismo right was she
very cultural is very no no we don't
speak about it we don't talk about it
yeah I chose not to even go that way but
the organ that bothers me let me say
what really bothers me yeah condom
commercials on TV period commercials
yeah they read commercials and bother me
it bothers me too
since I was a child that's the only
thing that's really well father's you
about it like when you say it bothers
you if there's a woman in the room what
bothers you about it like like what do
you feel like what like what feel that
like is it unnecessary I'm alone if I'm
alone yeah switch to commercial right
but there's a woman in the room and I'm
not having sex Willa it makes me feel
very uncomfortable
like what kind of period commercial like
like like tampon commercial yeah it
drives it makes you come up with the
I'll see your boyfriend invites me over
football yeah we're eating chips and
were smoking dope with the tampon
commercial come on yeah you won't hear a
peep out of me because I'm inside
boiling I'm just boiling inside and also
do we need tampon commercial ball game
why is there something let's somebody
got kicked in the [ __ ] why you know but
also don't we like do we need toilet
paper commercials we got it don't got it
do we have it by now we understand what
toilet paper we like wow I gotta wipe
their ass so what it what it you don't
like that it bleeds or what I just feel
I don't like that ugly nice but I have a
woman in the room and I gotta know her
secrets so yeah you're okay I got a
little soon ask a question she knows
that you know I don't want her to know
that I [ __ ] know okay so if when you
like your wife or arrant you're in a
relationship do not want to know do you
not like want her to talk about her
period with you I'm just a little okay
and what about do does it annoy you for
a girl you're in relationship with your
wife if they fart in front of you know
you that doesn't bother you go on look
that's a paradox to me do you think it's
a pic that's weird that one thing
usually exclusive the period thing
doesn't bother me the period thing today
is like you know you're driving you see
a stop sign yeah that's what I see just
what red yeah mine's more like a1 steak
sauce that's what I think
yeah you're welcome that's why I don't
like touching it looking at it when you
shoot some man they had think of that
brown blood you stab that brown look
that's what it is it's dark blood so
this oxygenated once I see that [ __ ] I
go down like a bag of potatoes is so
interesting but you'll eat [ __ ] right
as long as there's no blood around Wow
what comes out [ __ ] it let's do it it's
a part but you don't mind fart see I
don't know how many times I've had sex
with a woman and she said to all coked
up or something and she said to him a
man
my period and you're like no I'm putting
the dick in there with a condom in the
early eighties like a mean and I've gone
to the bathroom and I'm taking my condom
off and there's a little blood on my
condom you have no idea like I want to
go out there and stab if I go pee and
blood comes out of my pee because my
suction of might be after I nodded I've
never put my dick in a woman's ass as
she came up what's never come out if you
did if you did do you know bone a girl
in a butt yeah and then there was some
[ __ ] on your dick you'd be cool with
that you wouldn't have the same visceral
reaction I would go wash it off that's
so strange not strange I wouldn't
embarrass a woman and tell her you got
[ __ ] in your ass [ __ ] if she bled on
your dick would you sue would you freak
out I wouldn't say would you Damon you
business to embarrass a woman I didn't
really want to embarrass Tina like why
don't you [ __ ] tell me that you were
bleeding from you right I mean no guy
wants to hear putting that right context
number one I asked you like if you said
to me I'm on day two of my period you're
sucking dick duly noted the first second
third fourth fifth day those are the
dangerous days there's five days after
that where there's no blood but I can
smell the calcium and your and your puss
it's madama terrible blood like all that
it smells like gunpowder it smells like
it smells like napalm no flu or three
days it smells like gunpowder lips now
and then it's fresh again
but I know and people I know this is
offensive language to some people were
just talking the truth this is the truth
yeah
you know so for me there's a lot of men
including Lee but I've spoken with that
appreciate a vagina when a woman's
bleeding they said they think the sex is
better women I said I don't care he
doesn't care because a lot of girls get
horny or on their period on their period
yeah there's like days before and then
yeah right around I don't I mean I if
it's really bloody that's kind of I just
take a shower I always take a shower
after except for your neck yeah I have a
plastic wrap around my neck keep the
smell on but it's uh I don't I really
don't care I use a condom maybe feels
like I don't go like when super high but
like later I don't like don't touch me
uh my mother put up ten when I was a kid
I would clean the bar and I [ __ ]
stuck my hand to ten when they put the
periods seventies you would have
intended next to your toilet yeah yeah
we still have those period mother told
me it was a treasure there one day I
stuck my hand in I came out with a Kotex
don't look like a sophomore in the
seventies coat Texas were thick so when
you pulled the mothers I'm having a
sophomore and you're [ __ ] in the
chick was as big as you you had a towel
on your book it's like I shot you in the
[ __ ] there's so much code tanks so that
chiseled me right there I fainted that
bad that chiseled me right there and
then a combination of chiseled and gist
I could just just shattered my central
nervous system it takes a lot to shatter
kids in central nervous system that's
after my father died like you know I was
okay I was just getting better and I put
my hand in that [ __ ] box and I pulled
that period out with that codex and I
just sat there like how bad is this
because I put two and two together cuz
my mother my mother had had shock oh no
I did not know this so now today I did
not know this my mother had that shot
that women get when you put [ __ ] that
pussy's Jackson yeah so my mother used
to use he was so Cuban and so country
that my mom had a roll of cotton in the
bathroom
Wow she would just rip cotton off and
double it up and put it in a snatch when
I was a kid I don't even like to taste a
cotton like I wear is white t-shirt and
I still get them all the loops from like
like q-tips I got a wedding before I put
them in my because I don't like the
touch of cotton the touch the feel of
God a bad swing it is a weird
I would've been shot the first day I
don't you took gotta Africa to pick
cotton listen I rarely touch dynamite I
don't like time I build the wall I'll do
anything I'll get coal Chinese food I
don't like the touch of cotton ever I
wet q-tips before I put them in my ear
that's how much I hate you keep track of
all these rules because I just I don't
like [ __ ] cotton I never like copy
all from now my mother died my mother
dies at the time tonight my mother dies
I'm 16 and I'm a week into mourning my
mother's probably dead two weeks ten
days and I get a call girl that me and
her fooled around before no sex
a little sloppy spitty fingering us whoa
swapping spit yeah you know breaking out
the pool [ __ ] like that I can suck it no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no no no she wouldn't
even sell I wouldn't even ask at that
age would even consider sucking my dick
cuz your judge thirteen fourteen fifteen
have you sucked my dignity I cut off all
right that's how much of a Catholic ooh
that Wow so I call she called me up and
she was how you doin I heard about your
mother
good she does you mind if you do you got
you in the mood like we hadn't been
together in probably two years we
started were like 14 we messed around
for about three months and then we broke
up cause we both she went to a different
she went to Franklin and I went to
McKinley now they really see her and I'm
much anymore and after my mother died
she reached out and called me and said
do you want to see me tonight no yeah it
was called this [ __ ] my mother died
November 8th so give it ten days after
that it was freeze not a toast
she looked on 44th Street I lived on
38th Street I walk six blocks the 44th
Street and get it I mean it's worth it I
had to walk all the way back my house
weed upstairs we got a couple of those
[ __ ] wine coolers let's go upstairs a
rightist staying with me it's a ride I
don't give a [ __ ] she she would after my
mother died she just drink all day and
back cooked me dinner then pass out late
in the paint
well she was just gone my mother's
better
mostly was it who is that your sister
she was my mother's best friend oh sure
I remember walking up the stairs
bringing her in the room we made out a
little bit I put her under fire you know
I had some game your romantic at heart
aren't you at that age just smashing uh
y-you are you see my give a romantic no
I like the holding hands I don't like
the Roses on the bed I'm not the type I
don't want to take a tub with you I got
that what's our own way that goes people
you see at the table for two hours
holding on to each other yeah that's
never been me it's a lot I would be
uncomfortable for other dies I'm a
little horny at the time I had sex but
not really and he was what happened to
him this girl was putting on a silver
platter yeah took the shoes off I took
each leg off her pants and then what I
panties are gonna topple we dry humped a
little bit and then I pull back and I'm
about to take my pants off I start
she'll take my panties off oh I think I
just looked down and she's got this
[ __ ] pad in between the legs whoa
and when I pulled out the underwear
you're gonna joke the house you know the
house of love even though the house in
love in the roller coaster you know what
the house yeah yeah it goes there's
always a guy at the end they go wow yeah
this tongue is real long yep
was she the Kotex badly underwear like a
joke a tongue oh and it was filled with
blood oh man I held her legs and I
popped up like it was like a [ __ ]
like it had a disease like oh do you
have your period that she goes yeah but
it's only day one or day two I go you
got put those panties back on and she
goes why cuz I can't see blood it was a
disturbing nights of me dog I was pissed
off that the first time you ever seen
blood in that that was the first time I
saw that Kotex
he was on her period they like said yo
put your pants back I don't want to say
her name cuz she's past and I loved the
she was a great friend she was a good
friend to me after my mom died I put the
panties back in her jeans and then we
talked a little bit and she asked me why
didn't I like him I told I just don't
like blood
I don't do it needles nothing she was
all hard then we walked home on the way
home I was pissed off because my dick
was blue your dick was mad at you I
still remember that that's weed that
writer that I still in one night I came
home and that was balls tripping what'd
I tell you how much how far after your
mother's death was it this is two weeks
after my mom died about ten days after
my mom that it's not experiencing I saw
experimenting with the acid it was
working it was the one thing that made
me face it it made you face it how it
may be with you through the trip through
the trip and then immediately a Pink
Floyd put a song on the wall called
mother mm-hmm and then stuck in the Kazi
came out with a solo album mother please
forgive them they know not what they do
hug but those albums on and trip out
dude the acid and trip Island then just
try to put what happens together how
much acid would you do in one sitting
like back then back then at 14 you said
I was about I was 16 and what was it
like a I was doing it for about a year
now the kids are hanging out with would
do a hit on Fridays maybe a hit was
mescaline in those days right little dot
a little acid dot doc just put it right
in your tongue let it dissolve 45 to an
hour you done and how long was that high
for you how long was that trip Wow
and are there peaks and valleys in that
trip yes and are they high highs and low
lows high highs low lows were you like
come on leave let's go eat yeah the pass
it's going away and then we'd stop and
we'd let let's smoke a joint and you
smoke and as you walked into the diner
in the hot air we're here you you were
back now you would hear the [ __ ] eggs
for
Wow and you would hear every fort Wow
you're like I don't think I'm hungry no
more cancel my order and we'd walk out
of there and then we walk again for
another two miles you know and then we'd
sit somewhere I just remember going to a
cemetery and sitting in the semi when we
would push ourselves yeah to each other
to go get into bad situations on those
trips but I only knew one guy who really
had a bad trip and what Joe Looch what
was a bad trick like put his arm through
the [ __ ] Board of Education window
Wow
when it cut his veins and his arm and
the other people he would with tripping
and they didn't know how to react
imagine if all I say here tripping up I
mean [ __ ] off we forget about Lisa and
out of space I'm talking about where we
just give you - it's acid then we're
smoking pot with a little bit of beer
and you're just that flag is melting our
face is melting eye has turned in
different colors
these lights are trying in different
colors you go into a vortex for a little
while you go into a giggle vortex where
you start giggling at 10 o'clock and
it's 11:40 and you still get never done
how are you just laughing laughing
laughing anyway huh okay thank God that
was gone and let's go to your house who
was at yours my grandma she's sleeping
let's go over there but awesome that
night that's the night the grandmother
decides she's got insomnia we walk in
your house the acid hits her and she
starts talking to us about 1916 months
and I tried and now you're tripping your
ball vlog now you got another hour
dealing with that then you get out of
there and it would have peace and
valleys Thank You GU thank God that's
all it sounds like a nightmare it was
but when you're with your friends you
got no curfew New York City was wide
open
yeah woods by our house is wide open we
traveled in packs of six yeah
and I'm saying with two chicks and
nobody was [ __ ] the two chicks there
were gold bars you know and they want to
do acid with us and go behind like we do
ask them go into the woods and look at
the mood and then
you know we had a black friend he was
Dominican we had a black friend he was
Dominican but we called Luiza whatever
yeah but he was really Dominican and we
give me another piece on orange and we
get [ __ ] up isn't it good it's a sumo
enjoy yourself
what's his vitamin C yeah it's really
good for you you want some more lean
potato how hard we would trip at that
age we would blow pot smoke into his
afro and sit there and if you blow pot
smoke into an afro about three minutes
later the smoke rises out by itself and
we'd be tripping on a scope we'd be
looking at look at it look at it look at
the stock look at the way I turn into
snow in all different colors and that
would always start with streaks like
when we walk in the street and a car
will go past you yeah and you just go oh
my god because the lights the car would
stop and if they're always peaks and
valleys or or sometimes just all Peaks
and sometimes all valleys sometimes it's
a peak it's up like a [ __ ] to our
peak and then it go it just depends on
the dosages where you're at and I've
always I got to tell you something the
last 20 years I've become a [ __ ] I got
into do it and then we did the acid
podcast Atari yeah that was light ass it
was good acid yeah but it was like that
yeah you're not you're not breaking
through you're not breaking you're just
you and I I don't have it to break
through yeah it would break me now at
this age you would break you think so
yeah I think that would go deep and
bring up some skeletons but I forgot all
about your skeletons are showing up to
your shows oh my god that was first why
was it it's so weird how I put it up on
face I put it up on Twitter today
Facebook can handle it what is this real
and I'm really happy showed up when we
hugged we hugged through about four
minutes and without communicating that
everybody was telling me and I can we're
talking about the guy kidnapped maybe
seven he showed up to the shows his last
weekend in Tucson which the shows were
great in Tucson in Vegas thank you he
came up this treasure out but the Fox TV
I've been
together two shows in Tempe because he
lives in Tucson yeah and he always does
not calm but he's got a sick one well
and I don't think he ever really dealt
with it well this weekend I was in his
backyard he couldn't get out of
yeah when I got there I'm surprised he
didn't call to do dinner so when I got
to the show I said you know what now we
know the truth he doesn't want to see me
I don't blame ya and after the show
ended I came up mrs. Kent fellas here to
see and I was so happy
allowables and when the guys first so I
almost was driven to tears
mm-hmm then I hugged them and we now
have to say nothing isn't that amazing
I could feel what he was telling me and
I know what I was telling it yeah you
know [ __ ] writing on Twitter or no no
we used to see it and it was I forget oh
I said I'm sorry but what I did that was
really do she put myself in that
position
Wow you know I could feel with his body
what he was yeah the countability
we talked about you know what happened
to us over the years who he still spoke
it was very he's a really interesting
guy what is he doing now he sells solar
panels
Wow I was a manager at a solar panel
place that's the future it was always a
great sales yeah he was just lost just
like I was and he was hangin out with a
crew that you had to make a certain
amount of dough like you at like a limit
he was hanging out with a crew then
they're your friends and they'll cover
for you but you want to cover for
yourself
yeah do the same yeah you want to go out
sometime yeah Joey Mannion they would
they would never ever but to be part of
that crew you had to have a BMW Wow you
know their father owned the BMW dealer
so all the kids in a lot of pressure so
he he came from the other side of
Boulder you know I'm saying you know not
with these kids yeah I'm not with Jill
Goodacre who the [ __ ] is Joe good answer
Jill great is married to Harry Connick
jr. she'll Goodacre Joe good acres from
Boulder
like the wrong side of the track from
the right
child attraction Boulder she got hired
for Victoria's Secret at a ball
limitation she went to the same high
school I think it's Fairview it was
called and that's who sent out the call
brothers into the NFL Kevin call was an
outstanding offensive winder for the
Baltimore courts for years or pro that
high school had something Wow
and this kid came from that whole
wishy-washy thing and we sold cause of
the place called bill crowd supers I had
worked at this dealer has a car washer
for this bought body shop yeah and all
they did was cars from these this group
called the Crouch car group at that time
they had Honda Subaru Lexus they had a
couple different chains of cars
Mazda they had a couple different bowls
of things and I watched Carson's but
whenever I would drop him off at a
particular dealer the guy would always
go bro what are you gonna quit washing
cars his cell [ __ ] cause you're
killing yourself up to 20 hours a week
gangsters from Jersey the guy's name was
Peter Pinto Peter Pinto yeah so he came
bugging me bugging me until one day he
was showing on salesmen and he said hey
Monday I want to see an A in the class I
didn't know what to do on a Saturday
morning I dropped off a car and he goes
I'm short sells Monday politia show up I
had to call the body shop Monday morning
I can't come in there I'll be in there
tomorrow and I went there my first day I
read the pamphlets I will it then sold
three cars there no you did not [ __ ]
yeah I went borrow 500 for my so-called
mother-in-law and bought two suits and
two white shirt I quit the body shop and
then went to work at this bill Crouch
new rule I put my head to the ground
still in the first month I made like
seven thousand I was looking coke how
goes I was eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
tremendous I I bought more suits in the
second month I went in there so may 16th
up in college and got my four thousand
dollars in cash bonuses then I went to
third but the sold another 16 cars
well I made another like $10,000 in the
fourth month guess what happened you saw
more cars I meant no I got smart you
started stealing no I gots to smart when
you want to be a good salesman you don't
know that we got your mouth I don't know
how much of the car no that's my manager
huh
what's the wait I don't know your sounds
then when you get cocky you think you
know everything you go away from the
game plan oh I fell on my face I
couldn't handle the rejection so I quit
like a [ __ ] but that guy cat Vela
worked over there with a dude named
Carlos my verde a string of [ __ ]
killer salesman there what killers yeah
they would manipulate your mind so you
couldn't sell cars really oh yeah that's
good number like so they would sell more
yes sharks you're a good salesman
they'll come up to you let's [ __ ] with
Lita go jessimae what's that how about
working at this place
yeah did you know Kay it's called
pissing on your leg
so we piss on your leg and then jessimae
leaves and I come over and piss on your
leg for a little while and it's called
cracking it talking about sad things the
puppy got hit by a car two minutes and
sometimes it backfires I because then
you get said pissing on somebody's leg
and you piss on their leg after you get
him out of the game so that's one less
terrible which you and me against the
world he's at home grieving about some
[ __ ] but a dog at a dead dog yeah but
the guy who got hit with a wheelchair
you gotta hit him with a ukulele 15
times it's hysterical so we get him out
of the game these guys were professional
sports jams
anything to get your mind out of the
game so they could sell a county like a
miss roxelle a guy and a lot they
continued over manager wants to see you
and you're going to see the manager
what's the name did they bite he don't
want to see you
and he went got the up that's why you
had to stand your ground I let you learn
a lot by saying yeah so when I went down
it was a Duke Carlos Valverde go looking
do Boston I didn't know he was on her
the whole time yeah he was on heroin
that is that how he would sell he would
sell on heroin at him much time he
always disappeared no one day
cops came and told us they arrested them
for bank robbery it robbed six banks in
the area or something
this place was [ __ ] wild this place
had like eight so sound like a show
two of them were cool like legit white
people the other six were all like
Scott's so I quit there because my ego
couldn't take it I went to Chrysler
Plymouth and I met a Jew named art
Pressler that was a badass [ __ ]
Julian or herself
he sold coke too yeah uh well he was
selling cars oh yeah would it be in the
trunk no he would just sell it from his
death Wow did before salesman there I
learned how to [ __ ] in that's why I
wanna piss on people's like the top
salesman he had his favorite pet it was
a Red Cross he saw it up he would run
out there and talk to the up right when
he went to sell the car he'd bring him
in I'd steal the red and [ __ ] up his old
day then he'd be looking what's my lucky
red bag was my lucky red bag [ __ ] I love
you he'd be looking on the cars it would
break him it would break him he'd have
to go home a pen I would take his it
would take him out of his games I mean
if a pens taking another game were you
ever in the game oh my god and then
again he would get him up I'd steal his
pen this one on I worked there for maybe
five months you put it back would you
just put it back like I stole like a
stolen I got him for my 30 maybe 31 pens
Wow when I put him all the rubber bands
and they had those inverted ceilings
yeah and I put him in the ceiling and
the dad quit I gave him all the back and
he was like you [ __ ] I've been
looking all over for these I had that
dealership
I was called Hollister Chrysler Plymouth
I'm into how much of a slimeball that
was I had the keys to the southern
machine if things are bad I just robbed
the soda shows all the cause it was in
the [ __ ] Secretary's desk so I stole
them made duplicates how do you get a
key people life a lunch in those days
Joey banana you're the reason why they
invented cameras I said you are you 100%
Joey Diaz you're the reason for security
cameras
I hundred percent I harder so I I was
doing well at the Chrysler store but the
cocaine was killed me it was too
accessible there was no more calling guy
we just have to go on to work ah
Sela quad 11 and I'd thoughtful diagram
the blow how much does a grandma blow
then it was a hundred but it was
tremendous it was getting good coke
facade I don't even know much a condor
his dream is now she was a bad it was a
great cell he taught me how to sell
really good for now was prepared to go
back the crouch with the killers someone
back the crouch in November I went back
November first I started the month blow
straight they gave me a car I put him
together for a car a thousand dollar
advance because I was good yeah back to
crouch and then one day I read him
reading the paper like two days after
I'm back you crouch I'm reading the
paper by the guy who [ __ ] broke on it
the cops arresting her for a DUI and
while he was in the police custody at
the hospital he broke away broke into
the pharmacy stole several bags of pills
and other unnamed drugs and he jumped
out the window and the cops caught him
with something like that and the next
day two days later this kid comes out a
lot his name is Kent go home and they go
Bella's coming back today and he comes
back and he had stitches on his lip but
I know what happened goes honest Agathe
was arrested he had the handcuffs too on
like the red was around his wrists
though so he's telling me this whole
story about how he broke out of the
hospital he stole the liquid cocaine he
[ __ ] drank it I mean this guy was
nuts I mean you know I was watching
Scarface last night I was on Sunday it's
they said my wife associate was another
[ __ ] nobody over I [ __ ] him over but
he didn't have a comment all right he
was just at the bad place I bet all
right and this is after 32 years when
I've come up with what I remember who I
was the type of person I'm telling you I
would steal the [ __ ] soda machine the
soda machine guy wouldn't take the money
out he would leave singles and dollars
and then he was trying to mince the
hundreds the first time when it was like
eleven hundred dollars I couldn't but I
took like two hundred then I came back
to East and it was like 13
I took another 200 it was crazy I was
just Duplin 400 second ATM that's like
all this would you ever take a can of
coke also I take everything whatever I
wanted in the morning a couple sodas
fillet that ass brightener and at 200 so
when I went back he told me this stuff
he was the guy that got arrested and
then his bail was high and Gebhardt got
him out the guy who owned cars he did
yeah the guy who owned the car dealers
but he was running on the bail he was
I'm running on the bail I'm not doing
time for that they offered me four years
I'm not gonna do so I go what are you
gonna do he was well I'm staying with
this guy he's got two kilos of coke he's
holding but we have to do this quickly
because the guy who's holding the coke
for is coming back together the guy's
name is Randy Chambers his roommate so
right away that lived in my curiosity
enough my friends were in New York
having a good time yeah they were doing
a balls they were going to clubs Here I
am in this [ __ ] town
with these [ __ ] Gentiles I had a nice
girlfriend with her family but this was
no that was enough you needed to be
almost dying yes cool of like 7,000
wasn't enough and the card guy was
stealing and did you change I head out I
lift the two I lose in the house of
three people was a four bedroom a house
and it was two guys me and a chick the
chick was hot she was a redhead and she
had a little part-time living boyfriend
but I get coked up at night knock on a
door give her two lines and would be
working at her friend's was a diamond
dog I mean I have a girlfriend how the
demon you're consuming consuming
consuming so me is what I did yes old
cars you were a locust so when he told
me he was gonna run this guy could I
move the coke removed the two kilos
that's a nasty [ __ ] take that off
your hands quickly and I called my guys
laughter who am i doing
robbed this [ __ ] time so I called my
partner what am i doing I'm just I'm
gonna broker this deal with a brother my
bro am i doing I shouldn't do this my
[ __ ] broken myself so I said [ __ ] it
I'm gonna call a friend of mine I'm
gonna fly him out here
and we're gonna take this guy down New
Jersey's down then we'll go back to the
Jersey I'll leave this chick I'm done
with this life I'm lying to myself I'm
not a car sale I'm a coke dealer I want
to go back with my friends dog I miss my
friends I missed my wife yeah I missed
all that craziest [ __ ] insanity I was 25
years old I was dumped my friends are
going up to hunt the mountains blowing
coke every weekend eat quaaludes and I'm
out here watching the Denver Broncos
it's gonna be a [ __ ] parade come here
they can thank Grand the mud seven grand
a month so I said ok and I went to a guy
that I bought weed from and coke and
this guy was a [ __ ] [ __ ] just a
typical [ __ ] [ __ ] he had every
accessory a loser could have you know
I'm saying pink you make a jacket tattoo
on the forearm when he rolled the jacket
up see this successful you know this is
87 guys way before the tattoo revolution
he had done time he had tempted windows
he had a lot stereo he had a [ __ ]
pitbull did a lot of strip clubs
so far I'm rest his hand for eight he
was just myself but I bought drugs from
so I went up to him he said he ran with
some bikers I know if I could do it try
it I said okay I want to rob this dude
and he's like okay I'm in bah-bah-bah
that his motivation for still robbing
this guy it was completely different
than mine yeah what was his his
motivation was he had met a stripper
dancer at a lewd place not even the
topless place a new place was BYOB the
chick was tremendous I saw a couple
times she left her husband and she was
sleeping in his house now
oh man he gave her his bed and he slept
on the couch and he professed his love
to her but she told me she loved him
also
well [ __ ] she was a Catholic I'm white
and for her this stripper and then a
Catholic for this sleep with him he
would have to
divorce that she didn't feel comfortable
it was against her religious beliefs I
mean six hours ago she had a snail trail
going down a pole
how much is your divorce it was $10,000
and he needed the 10,000 Rob this guy
with me to give this girl the money plus
he's so powerful she could get a divorce
and [ __ ] him [ __ ] is so she slept on
his couch was six weeks he slept on his
couch because she has got she lived in
the bedroom get her life together bring
it on the guys over there you know like
just the guy was a [ __ ] lady so I take
him I set him up his mother holding a
lot of real estate in Boulder she was
like a rental and he said he had an open
house he goes why don't you bring him
over there and we'll rob him over there
so my plan was to [ __ ] like to be
real easy my plan was to bring him over
there show him some cash make him go
back get the coke and when he came back
we just handcuffed him and put him on a
box we gave my two thousand dollars and
said get on a [ __ ] bus it's over for
you don't come back and we'll shoot you
that was the original plan I mean that
even sounds risky that plan sounds risky
too
oh it was horrible so and how is the
setup that I'm the son of God I mean are
you service thinking about all that I
like leading up to that moment I'm
[ __ ] my pants just listening to this
story listen I did make it all this way
because I didn't have balls of steel I
know balls a [ __ ] we can have balls
of steel and also be apprehensive about
that sort of scenario of my life there
was no apprehension you weren't even
thinking I was 25 and I was chasing a
lifestyle that didn't exist yep
I took that this lifestyle would they
would include me in that Club right and
that was all that money was going to do
was ruin me right that's all that money
at that age would do and so you plan to
meet this guy have to meet this guy at
1:45 on November 18th to what one
o'clock at his house
and then drive you to the other guy's
house my partner in the kidnapping
tell him everything was kosher and then
do what I said drive him back bring him
back and do the exchange tell him it was
a ripoff I'm getting ripped off also put
someone in his pocket my pocket
you know drop me off on a corner kick me
out of the car
punch me in the mouth make it look good
make it look good I didn't get rid this
guy in a [ __ ] bus
that was the deal no I go to pick up the
guy and go upstairs right away when I
get upstairs he takes me into the room
the one online yeah he gives me a line
of the coke and right when he opens the
drawer it's a grinder but it's $2,000
and the grinder was rocks because in
those days the grinder to grind up coke
at an apartment that you could take the
top off and put a lid on it and you
could hold a [ __ ] half ounce of that
alright so when he opened the grinder
there was [ __ ] a half ounce in there
I saw with my eyes he took a rock out we
grinded we'd to a line and I can see the
I go how much cash is that it was 2000
he doesn't want to take that too
so he already had a plant so no let's go
let's go over take a sample from the
roof you took a rock out and he was
gonna bring it to my guy my guy whips
out a [ __ ] machine gun and he's like
Joey tie him up and I'm like this wasn't
the plan you dumb [ __ ] this
wasn't the plan you stupid [ __ ] so now I
had to turn Joey on so now I'm sitting
here with the guy he goes I'll leave him
with you and I go well then see what's
over
I read Bella Bella didn't tell him where
the kilos were and neither did I I go
it's over there somewhere
but there's money in the drawer and this
coke and the [ __ ] grinder I didn't
tell him how much alright so he walked
with a choice I didn't find any coke
there was just a gram and the grind that
ah and there was only 300 hours cash ah
so I go really
and he goes yeah and he started smacking
Vala whatever tell us what a coca
isabella goes I don't know I don't know
and I said you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ]
right there is what I realized that that
dudes robbing me yeah
so I go you know [ __ ] this is your
mother's house you figure out what to do
it he was you better not leave me I'm
gonna shoot you and I remember walking
towards the door I turned there
you got the [ __ ] balls to shoot me
that went out to my car and I had a gun
in the trunk I had an old 9-millimeter
beautiful one that pay like six allows
for an Aston and for a second I'm like
I'm gonna shoot both these [ __ ]
because I know what time right now I
knew I was going to jail right at that
moment I knew there was no coming back
I was already in deep I lived the clip I
cocked it and it was like God just
stepped in and said don't just get in
your car and awesome my mind race I go
let me go into Coke I'll come back with
these dumb [ __ ] I don't weigh like
through the [ __ ] gun in the trunk and
I went over there you know in I went
back to the guys apartment door man in
the apartment building and just saw me
with Vela coming out and then Ted Wald
went over there with his keys I didn't
take the keys and Tidwell said walked
when I was leaving
so I basically went over to had the door
man open the door for me I walk to the
elevator I pressed the button I walked
to the floor and when I made that turn
around the elevator I'd know what
apartment I was going to and I just
kicked the [ __ ] door down haha the
door went flying off the [ __ ] hinges
with no gun no gun no I had my gun in my
back put my my waist yeah I knew the guy
wasn't there he worked as a service guy
at some car dealership yeah but my
gorilla foot kicked that door the whole
[ __ ] floor hurt and I went in and
they had one of those ceilings that
holds up those tiles that you could push
up and yeah old school yeah I jumped up
like a gorilla cuz I knew was under one
of those tiles I just didn't have time
to look under each one and get a chair
you know changes I mean I kicked the
molding and everything huh
like I just really can't that's what
Adrenaline's call that's what it's
calling when somebody's in the pinch I
just could really kick that door and
when you're on coke do because I want to
be alert mm-hmm I don't like one little
little tiny head
nothing the adrenaline had blown that
Kolkata damn no coke involved I just
grabbed that [ __ ] seething and ripped
it down like a gorilla I think just a
top 10 awesome boom I felt the two
little things they were wrapped in
Columbian newspaper rapidly tape
basically put under my arm and walked
out of it
and people in the hallway like people in
the hall we're really going what's going
on I just walked out and then can't they
saw my face in them it would you do with
the coke I went out I put the trunk of
my car
I took off I made a u-turn and I hid it
under a newspaper been right on Canyon
you open up newspaper
yeah underneath there's a little special
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a weed
high on coke in the old days when you
deliver the kilo you don't nobody see
you or half a kilo or an ounce you hit
it the newspaper business so when you
open up my dad always went there when
you open up a newspaper from now on
don't look at the newspapers there's a
retirement plan under there a lot of
people didn't know and the same is it
how they believe the corners in there
for the week looks like they had some
people leave quarters you just didn't
look you were lazy Wow pull one
newspaper right yeah him dummy there's
nothing under there I called my body at
work I told him to get a car from his
dealership put fake plates on and take
the coat to Aspen I said take a chunk
out and drop it off by the house would
even buy a chunk I don't know break a
[ __ ] piece off the kilo I'm pulling
the bag and drop it off for me
and then he dropped it off and he will
have to Aspen and I sat there thinking
while I was on top of cops that would my
next move I had cash coming back from
the kilos so I was good I just had to
stick it out for two or three days and I
had money so I knew the cops would be
looking for me when who maybe the guy
was gonna look for me who owned the coke
right I knew somebody was coming to my
house so I said well I'll worry about
let me get this coke go crusty through
the bar have a couple cocktails and I
will know what the hood bought a couple
cocktails and I went back to the house
and drank I got so coked up I passed out
and I woke up on the couch to blazing
Brett Hayes it knocking on the [ __ ]
dog Oh Joey open the [ __ ] door the
cops are looking for you you like get
that ten minutes
and helping the drunker what's going on
it was [ __ ] they got those
dealerships around it cops all up there
looking for you what you do I don't know
it's a little over your addresses but
that comment so I grabbed everything
that me and Brent I went up to the
corner was look uh King Soopers that's a
supermarket chain yeah
in Boulder and I went there and I called
my girlfriend I told her what I had done
it backfired the cops are looking for me
and she said I'll come get you and I
checked my pockets I realize I didn't
have my weed with me left without my
weed so I walked around the back of the
neighborhood jumped in my house in front
of my house I jumped in took my weed in
my pipe and I left
thank you went back for your weed when
the cops are supposed to let you know
the state of mind
Wow but that night before before I left
to get coked up there was a knock on my
door and it was kid well my partner yeah
and he had Bella in the trunk of the car
already
and he came oh and he goes hey okay you
got me but we still got to make money I
need money for that divorce and he goes
as a guy with a clown - staying at a
hotel up the road let's go take that I
so you go take that you're on your own
he goes if you don't [ __ ] come with
me or some [ __ ] I'm gonna call the cops
or whatever the [ __ ] it was and I just
oh my god cuz I knew I was already in
trouble
I didn't know what was gonna happen you
owe me today what happened nothing
the guy was driving Bella to the bus
station and it was a bad neighborhood he
was driving without his headlights on
you would have gotten pulled in the
cuffs I wouldn't have been in a car I
would've never been in that car I was
his job yeah I don't put myself in a car
like that that's that that's why they
were stole the car like stone cuz cuz
you got no no alibi yeah you're in the
car you're already in the car
you're screwed so he said license
registration yard
the guy was in the back of the trunk and
they opened up the trunk and Bella never
ratted here's what you guys gotta
remember
Vala the victim never ratted it was
Tidwell that told him everything just
remember that that's how and then I got
sentenced and the whole thing and then I
came out how long what was your sentence
six years zero six
no no work what a we conciliate
what a reconsideration though so after
120 days I could send them a
reconsideration no reconsider my
sentence and did they yes the four years
Department was it the first time you
served time yeah that was the only time
Wow when I came out I didn't bump into
them I went back to New York I got it to
calm I got out of 90 I got to come in 91
I fell on my ass in 93 when I came back
in 94 I bought coke I bump into another
barn Boulder and I bought coke oh my
circle but he was he had a scar on his
face they go what happened it was after
you kidnapped me I got kidnapped again
and he was like you know you know he was
just in a cycle oh yeah you know and
that's how you guys got her you get
stuck in that [ __ ] this is a drug psycho
he was hanging out with major drug B
yeah people pulling guns and all that
[ __ ] he's stuck in them that's a nice
white guy from Boulder you know he
didn't want no [ __ ] problem
yeah he was just a nice white guy for
bald looking for love in all the wrong
places
that's it did he ever get the money for
the divorce though the guy the other
dude
they gave him ten years wait he
confessed and he got more time than you
because he was on parole ah weapons the
guy was in his car he really had no yeah
he really had no alibi and then he just
ratted on all of us that was just funny
than am i Shh
that fella never said a word it was
general I told him that isn't it how it
always works though it's always like the
dude that's not it's not like
victim so much as it is like just the
ratty [ __ ] in the group he didn't
testify because I plea bargain so he
didn't have to testify in court
Vala testified in court and talked about
his experience that he was put in the
closet with a pitbull and all this [ __ ]
because this fella this [ __ ] long guy
has a pitbull
so after I left there saying so what my
attorney had to prove was that I didn't
have knowledge that this was my defense
but I always knew what I had done I felt
shitty enough so we're gonna take it to
trial but if I lost I get 48 years I'm
gonna do this for all the shitty ID
things I didn't start over it's gonna go
balls in balls it and you only got four
that's it then they reconsider the four
with Community Corrections and all this
[ __ ] I had a tag on my volunteer work
and all this [ __ ] what was like the day
you got out do you remember what was the
first thing you did eat I would have
mentioned just go eat no you go to the
halfway house okay
can you eat TV dinners oh I think you
really should eat food ah you're already
used to [ __ ] prison food should be
fun yeah what a business then let us
stand for 72 hours for orientation they
had a piss you see the levels of all the
drugs and rhinestones and all that stuff
then they let you out from 9:00 to 5:00
to get a job what was your job what was
your first job detail what does that
even mean Joey detailing what detailing
that [ __ ] so what I did was I got a
pager all they wanted was to call the
place and be able to get a hold of you
and talk to you right so if I would say
them I'm going to [ __ ] jessimae house
I got a right now I'm just amazed um and
just my address and the time to time
they would call Jess amazed and so what
I would do is I gave my pager number
and the Geoghan crazy because I said I
worked in a dealership oh that was there
I didn't have a job I didn't have a job
at all I didn't have a job at all there
was a garage I hung out and talked [ __ ]
with the owners there all day but I
didn't have a job
were you just back into the hustle I was
just back into the house Wow I remember
I wasn't allowed to drive when there was
a light in the car next to one of the
counselors and I'm like if this [ __ ]
looks over here I'm done I used to put
the seat back no I just looked the other
way than the light turn green and she
went and I just stayed there made a left
I mean I was hell on wheels I didn't
that I gave him too high you the first
piss test I gave me bad was million from
snorting coke and touching it from
weighing it it was going my fingers it
was a hellacious [ __ ] time and it was
all brought upon by me God didn't do it
to missus I didn't do it today no
choices you mean yeah it was all my
fault accountable for it it was all my
[ __ ] you know it was not gonna do it
nobody else it was just this a spell of
[ __ ] lies that's it do you believe do
you believe anybody who's in that life
can get out yeah I did
it took 15 more years after I got out of
jail to realize what was the final point
for you that you realized you didn't you
wanted to live out you don't want to
live in that life anymore I was here in
LA performing [ __ ] game in comedy I
had already booked movies and films
MADtv what about this life is more
alluring comedy you gotta remember what
life are you talking about the shelves a
drum like what a dramedy pull you out of
that life because it seems like that
life was so ingrained in you at that it
became my first love I knew that it once
I got the taste of it I got my you know
what I'm onto something right I don't
want to admit it to myself and nobody
else so the other life was luring
the other life was getting all right
you'll get bored of reading oh yeah
being broke yeah desperate and always
wanna do
all right I was attracted to [ __ ]
filthy women that don't want to do coke
right thankin it just gets old
they got old and I find myself caring
for somebody when did you meet your wife
in 2000 and it took me seven years to
stop yeah so she was in the mid in sorry
in the Crossrail er
wow that's a writer die lady right there
yeah she met you coming out of that life
yes you're still in it though seven
years
Wow she loves you seven years that was
productive individual yeah but still
sorry you came home at five and I'm on
the couch playing yeah yeah yes but
that's not me at all right you know when
she got home to five there was vacuuming
was done the dishes were done the
bathroom was clean I was just a Coquette
yep I was uh you know I still sent all
this [ __ ] I talk about breakdowns and
yep all this [ __ ] right that was all in
the coat so that's why it'll probably
roof on che right you got to get up
every day yeah you gotta work it you got
out if I was doing it this time when I
was not until five then getting up at
[ __ ] 8 I mean come on heart attack
City and I would go home at 3:00 and
watch Law & Order at dum-dum
and take a little nap it was to be on AV
3 2 5 2 hours 3 hours I got up to four
hundred and eighteen pounds
whoa not sleeping well you don't sleep
oh it messes up all of you and your
hormones get messed up your circadian
systems all messed up because of you
know that's your your sleep regulation
so now that's why I don't do those late
shows at the Comedy Store you got a
10:30 show the time you leavin Bob I'll
do a 10-15 spot yes I know I'm getting
out of that ten yeah and I'm in the car
live at 10:30 yeah you know after I got
off stage there's no there's no Joey
Diaz yeah my house wakes up at 6:15 yeah
[ __ ] around at night yeah I did that it
right there life well I got into comedy
from 2004 to 2009
I didn't know what TV was right there
was no TV no play baseball right I
didn't know who play football my life
was calmly yep I was on the road I was
with doing truck Tribble runs in what's
the other guy Yoder runs yeah you know I
was out there I didn't have time to
[ __ ] I'm trying to make 50 bucks
yep just spend 45 on blowing weed right
that's five holes for breakfast yeah I
would wake up with a 5 to tip the
[ __ ] weight to have at the hotel
hopefully it's a buffet you have no
credit card on file Jewish I would call
the club his llama the bond that lost my
ATM card before I came here and you
bring $50 over or something and they go
come over and get it I was relentless I
just Wow see and that's like your your
story is so interesting to me because it
really highlights that you're your own
not you I mean people in general you're
your own worst enemy and honestly you
can get out of the situation you're in
if you just launch if you exactly if you
want this takes time yes not gonna rome
wasn't it's not easy you have to write a
path out yep like I just knew that I
knew after long as your I came up that
was my darkest
problem with the drugs like that yeah
like a dark year nothing really happened
for me Tracy Morgan got a show [ __ ]
the dude from Brooklyn nine-nine they
put him on Chris Rock show you know
everybody looked up after that my career
stayed the same or even got worse right
so I had a hard time and then I just saw
a lot of people having a hard time
following me at the store yeah and
you're like well what else [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] that's around me this is really
only had two good things this brought at
the house in this comedy and then you
made that your nucleus then when I
stopped in 2007 I remember the other
gift baby had never lost
I had never lost it but I haven't used
it either what's that my balls
I was balls crazy from the cocaine and I
was balls crazy from
but I remembered who I was where I came
from
and how I was gonna happen one point
thought and I didn't play the Hollywood
game anymore oh not that I ever played
it but now I didn't tolerate it right
and I'm one of my first missions after
the cocaine thing was a commercial for
Hardee's and just to make a long story
short the guy said some [ __ ] to me just
cuz he had a tattoo of a hat with a
feather in it or those guys the director
his arm rolled up my assistant and I
would offer them and he were hitting
this trailer and he's like you're fired
I go wait who are you gonna get it to in
the morning to shoot Long Beach you're
gonna waste Hardy's budget they're gonna
fire you come out here apologize like a
[ __ ] man and let's get on with this
did he oh yeah I've never been spoken to
here cuz you're a [ __ ] and it's time
that somebody did speak to you yeah and
he's like respect that a [ __ ]
director who gives a [ __ ] what you do
you went to school I'm at the Comedy
Store [ __ ] every [ __ ] night yep
gunning for my life so next time you
yell at a white kid that doesn't know
any better that thinks you really worth
your weight in gold you better check
yourself you ain't [ __ ] you put your
pants on one leg at a time just like the
rest of us and this [ __ ] yeah
and once I became nothing as much work
anymore I got a little tough to work
with but always there germophobe life
smack in the mouth either shake my hand
I went out one time no sadly yeah I
stand them down do a movie about the the
Howard Hughes in what were you staring
at him for his little lobsters to throw
him out of the hotel we had to throw
Howard Hughes our little town right so
we get there to rehearse we're just
sitting there and he's talking about
[ __ ] what's-her-name with added to
his ex-wife he's still talking about the
bar really Christie Brinkley what was
her name
chef Shh doesn't matter whatever yeah
and then directly goes right we're
getting ready to shoot they start
looking at all of us like we played for
gangsters
then when it came to me stunts like that
like eyeballing man I'm like I look at
this puffing [ __ ] wants to play i ball
with the mast of the eyeball because I'm
in the court I've been
against judges you can't take your eyes
off while the judge is looking at you
can't take your eyes off a judge that's
weakness yep so will the judges look at
me you gotta [ __ ] with us write down
like I you blinked already twice I
haven't [ __ ] well he had a breakaway
cuz I'll [ __ ] work it yeah I've been
court trained I'm [ __ ] I know how to
put my I'll tell you though that's what
you need to do that's yeah your parents
teacher that's why you never seen me
with sunglasses in the car now because
I'm older but as your kid I love some
guys weren't allowed to wear sunglasses
like rub really yeah people wouldn't
talk to you take them [ __ ] things off
I got dry eye today
my name's her brother bothering the [ __ ]
out of me oh it's always a pleasure wait
you just I don't want to leave you um I
was just gonna say something wait so
Alec Baldwin you stare at you stare them
down then what and then he took his eye
balls off me and we shot the scene
that's it nothing else happening didn't
talk to me those guys it's max cab
driver ISM you know he does Matt cab
drivers that's right tough guy with this
ten people yeah yep
fluffing his feathers they never see if
he really got loud with me I would have
bitch-slap them and the gay community
would have something like that the gays
can't stand that [ __ ]
I need your movie I need your I need the
story about you
I'm just happy told I'm just happy to
kid [ __ ] showed up shook my hand and
I made my peace that's pretty that
really amazed not gonna make peaceful
all you said no you're not you can't
you're not gonna make peace for you know
what the ones you can at least try a
little bit yeah that's all I ask it's
both sides though no I know all the
people that I can't reach out there I
have people in my heart I'm dying to
reach out to and I can't because I know
how they're gonna come at right so I
just leave it to God yeah you gotta
leave it you just you let it go but he I
like that this dude came to you and also
said he was he took a counter
for where he was in his life he was a
[ __ ] who got kidnapped he said
he put himself in that position that's
interesting most people want to do that
it's dirty two [ __ ] years ago that's
wild
almost as long as I've been alive that's
all that's that's insanity
that's why I tell people what I'm doing
jokes you can't judge people mummy you
can't well somebody did thirty is it no
well let it go I know 50 people who have
been completely different people but I'm
still [ __ ] crazy you're still a
[ __ ] Savage you've got a dates coming
up you dirty [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna be
traveling round I'm gonna be in Japan
this week for another USO tour Jesus
Christ I'm going to Japan tomorrow and
then I'll be in Atlantic City at the
Hard Rock Casino a new one yeah at 19th
20th and 21st it's a club yeah and how's
the boyfriend what's going on he's just
adorable we do all that stuff yeah you
got keep it fresh yeah you know [ __ ]
and HD you got to keep it clean all over
the world this is Chinese people are
working like they're stuck in a factory
making my phone there's Russians into
something that [ __ ] hopefully hopefully
it's not just going to one place I'm
gonna get no Commission's I should get I
should get some Gucci Commission that's
what I'm talking about
you [ __ ] in Japan restore your Godzilla
hey can I get a couple coins something
Godzilla picked a karate suit for my ihd
coochie where's my coochie Commission
you you're right I gotta start I should
start charging anybody who sees it
really let alone I'm so scared I sent a
dick pic you should be you have to yeah
I would imagine yours looks like like a
like a extinct animal but something
really mystical you let yourself go
you know what I've seen some nuts in my
day nothing like those Imagineers look
like Parade Float oh my god
they have like like a Thanksgiving Day
Parade Float I just remember like being
19 and chick sucking my balls it was a
big a banana and what they thought like
them that was good a lot more than what
they thought and they just look at you
with those big eyes like I didn't know
it wasn't a good thing that's just one
of them Jesus Christ
they're like bags filled with money oh
my god I wasn't I was in Miami one time
yeah and I met this girl and baldon we
were friends were good friends I liked
him a lot I think she was a freak on the
side and that's what made me like her as
friends I've never really tried my
because it was too easy it was easy but
then she was living in Miami and that
changed what the man is and she showed
up at the club we got blow and then
she's like where's your hotel room so my
[ __ ] party thought no she's the one
that's saying it won't when I went to
attack she's like before you know I'm on
my second dangling let's not talk about
it I want some action
so I said what you want to do and she
goes what I'd love to suck balls and
we're on the balcony
it was floor than one of a coked-up I
chose never and she was sitting him like
one of those [ __ ] chairs lounge
yes like a pool chair I guess for the
more than a porch and I climb over to
pull the chair like a horse like John
Wayne before the races comments and I
just and she looked at me she goes I
hope your paws don't smell really bad I
go no I just watched him like an hour
ago I didn't watch him in six hours and
I just did two shows at the improv there
with two little sweat balls of death I
put that ball into her mouth and she
looked at me she's like just one ball I
had just one ball she goes Jesus Christ
one of the size of these things and this
had to be 25 years ago now that I'm 50
that down to ones down to my kneecap and
the other ones down halfway like my left
nuts bigger than my right nut you have
to be ambidextrous
well if you're lefty you're not your
right nut is bigger oh so if you're it's
longer you gotta use your hands both
your hands yeah so by using this hand
yeah it's like you know when you pull it
robot right it's like a puppet not
enough it nothing yes I got nothing so I
grab onto your nut so you're righty
you're left much bigger than your right
then a lesson for everybody well so much
science on this episode it has to be
it's of Tuesday how can I leave him here
last day a month Black History Month
they still upset about Jesse small atoms
and people are going nuts
everyone's offended everyone's offended
get some sleep and learn a language if
you're offended take a nap and learn a
new skill that's what I say I'm happy
you got time to come on the show I
always chat with your podcast yes so
please let's put it together what do you
tape uh uh uh all things comedy studio
yes I was just there before yeah I would
love to have you on I got a do Mike
Tyson on Wednesday whoa I'm gonna go
smoke some weed yo he's gonna have you
met him then he's gonna [ __ ] love you
have my face time with him he is going
that is I'm going so epic I'm going down
to the spark with him for two hours oh
my god that's amazing
you're gonna be so much fun Oh boxes
yeah [ __ ]
oh that's amazing that's gonna be
awesome and then next weekend the 7th to
the [ __ ] 9th Houston Texas I'm
coming home [ __ ] Carabas
[ __ ] Blueberry Hill
tamales [ __ ] Chuy's [ __ ] I'm
coming home you [ __ ] up as it's over
it's been too long
coming back to the improv Thursday
Friday Saturday Saturday late show's
already [ __ ] sold out so you don't
jump on these ticket thing you're gonna
be [ __ ] goons I'm telling you right
now don't come hit me up on facebook
Messenger Joey there's no tickets what
am I gonna do go [ __ ] yourself that's he
gonna [ __ ] do I want to take jessimae
Peluso I want to thank you guys I want
to thank and find you for [ __ ] doing
this today all right
the podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace calm turn you're cool idea
into a new website okay start showcasing
your work blog or publish content sell
products and services of all kinds
and promote your physical or online
business announce an upcoming event or
special project and more you could do
all this with Squarespace why you create
your own website beautiful templates
created by world-class designers with a
powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online the
ability to customize the look the feel
the settings the products and more with
just a few clicks
everything is optimized for the mobile
right out of the box it's a new way to
buy domains and choose from over 200
extensions and analytics that help you
grow in real time and a built-in search
engine with top optimization free and
secure hosting and 24/7 award-winning
customer support
that's what Squarespace gives you so do
me a favor head over to squarespace.com
for a free trial when you're ready to
launch all right use promo code church
and save 10% off your first purchase of
a website or domain guys we've been
talking about your goals this is it
it starts with squarespace.com and the
code church the church is also sponsored
by audit comm listen don't make me
[ __ ] go over there hit your head with
a pipe alright go to on it right now
look at the fine line of supplements you
gotta [ __ ] jump out the window with
the [ __ ] they got to offer with alphabet
listen you get alpha brain it don't work
for you you're still hearing voices and
[ __ ] like that you keep it you call on
it and they send you the money back
that's how much we believe in our
product when somebody believes in their
[ __ ] product that much you have to do
business with them you understand me so
go 200 not calm right now press in
church BAM and get 10% off your first
door again I want to thank jessimae
Peluso again I want to thank the Flying
Jew but I want to thank you
[ __ ] for being family if
they're having gonna back here at the
church or what's happening now like I
told you Houston Texas
Irvine improv Houston March 7th through
the 9th the party starts Thursday night
if I was you I get a nice 25 tickets on
Thursday you come in solo tell the wife
you're gonna shoot yourself I don't give
a [ __ ] about your time bring a [ __ ]
suit suits and we'll get this [ __ ]
party started
next Thursday Friday and Saturday at the
Houston improv and that's it and that's
that I love you guys I'll see you early
Thursday
ready to flop and Rock stay black take
this [ __ ] mealy